L'eau ne doit pas être monétisée,
ne doit pas tendre 1 produit spéculatif,
1 marché, 1 bien de concurrence
où on achète des volumes à la hausse ou à la baisse.
Ces réserves
ne doivent pas être appréhendées uniquement par des
énormes structures,
notamment céréalières,
exclusivement exportatrices
et dont le
capital n'est plus détenu par les intérêts français
et qui représente 1 modèle d'exclusion, de fête,
des indispensables petites
et moyennes exploitation agricole.
Enfin, la gouvernance doit interroger,
ces ouvrages sont fortement subventionnés,
leur gestion
ne doit donc pas complètement échapper à l'état
et à ces agences de l'eau,
gages de régulation,
de transparence et d'appréciation des impacts.
Il y a donc beaucoup à dire, beaucoup à travailler,
mais surtout pas pour ne rien faire pendant 10 ans,
à part des aides,
surtout sur des problématiques
qui sont au Carrefour de
notre souveraineté alimentaire
et du réchauffement climatique.